ça recommence
mais c'est pas mal ça
[Musique]
c
[Applaudissements]
j'ai maintenant la touche mais on bosse
on a dancefloor on leur a dit on va dire
complètement maintenance une émission
médias et donc au printemps ça c'est
fait ça fait rêver
matt pokora et ses danseuses c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
alors becker ou pas avec qui je suis
venu pour danser choléra la non mais tu
vas euro mettez pas la musique fait pas
de bombe victimes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
vas tu j'aimerais franchement con mettre
une petite musique on a le roi de la
danse ici pour moi tu es le numéro sont
à le roi de la danse qui est là c'est
mathieu deslandes
je peux te dira si ça fait longtemps
qu'il n'a pas dansé
j'aimerais que pour cette première on
fera une petite bataille d'audace autre
match
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment
[Applaudissements]
pas mal
à l'école et il ya un nouveau pack vous
fiez pas avant je suis là l'opa de la
momie la momie je connaissais pas sur
pattes juste comme ça en acapulco la le
pas de la momie deux pas de là mon match
je le connaissais ce pas toi
non vraiment à glomel piqué pour une je
reviens non c'est bon il a ce qu'il faut
non mais
rejeté tout cela des reculs nos fins
attendant une heure et demie merci
matthieu delormeau robert sud n'a pas
fait
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]